la scène se passe devant l'écologiste de
dealers fin vers 17 heures l'heure
habituelle j'avais surtout de 20 minutes
avant une voiture a explosé juste devant
onze personnes ont été blessées
les enfants étaient encore à l'intérieur
seuls trois d'entre eux ont été
légèrement commotionné avalant du frac
le bilan aurait pu être bien plus grand
la détonation a été forte
la voiture s'est immédiatement enflammé
où le feu s'est propagé dans un immeuble
voisin
selon un collaborateur du grand rabbin
de lyon la cour était juge celle de
boules ont fait office les écoles qui a
échappé de peu au drame abri 700 élèves
du jardin d'enfants à la troisième
pour récupérer porte maintenant